علامه صنع او ميد ان ظهرت لاول مره في
انجلترا عام
1887 عندما صدر قانون يجبر الشركات
الاجنبيه التي تصنع منتجات بريطانيه مقلده
ومنخفضه الجوده على توضيح اصل منتجاتها
العلامات التجاريه تدرك التاثير الذي
سيحدثه ملصق صنع فيه على قرار الشراء لذلك
تستخدم بعض الشركات تلك العلامه كاداه
تسويقيه ليس الا هذا يعني انه اذا كانت
الشركه تصنع منتجا في اسيا لقله التكلفه
تكلفه الايادي العامله ثم اضافت التفاصيل
النهائيه في روما فلا يزال بامكانها
استخدام ملصق صنع في ايطاليا لكن في
الولايات المتحده مثلا معاييره وضع علامه
صنع في امريكا صارمه جدا بحسب لجنه
التجاره الفيدراليه يجب ان تكون معظم
الاجزاء التي يصنع منها المنتج مصنوعه
داخل حدود البلاد
استطلاعن اجرته منصه ستاتستا عام 2017 شمل
اكثر من 43 الف مستهلك حول العالم يقيس
درجات الاحترام لملصقات صنع فيه جاءت
المانيا في المركز الاول يليها سويسرا ثم
علامه صنع في الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]